if I give somebody a relative a thousand
bucks okay so the last thousand dollars
gonna give me I'm telling you bro I'm
gonna pay you back 1500 bucks in two
years yeah never get it back okay two
years later you come back to me hey this
time give me five thousand but I promise
you I'm gonna fix I'm gonna give her
back 10 grand yeah okay no here you go
two years that he comes back up dude
this time I'm asking for 10 but I'm
changed right I'm good bro trust me give
me the money I'm gonna fix it
if you give it the third time you're an
idiot in my eyes we keep giving money to
people with zero accountability and we
just keep saying here he goes why are
you talking about 1.9 trillion dollars
but you know for what programs any
programs any programs that were given
money to that there's no accountability
for which is being wasted any one of
them
[Music]
[Applause]